you
oh thanks Brad you know I've been
playing Battlefield as long as I can
remember
and over the past 16 years these games
have come a long way from 1942 to bad
company to Battlefield 4 and up to
Battlefield 1 and today I'm taking on
the most important mission objective
I've ever been a part of telling all of
you about battlefield 5 I'm geared up
ready to go my squads up there so let's
deploy because we are live in London
let's get the show started
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
welcome everyone to the battlefield 5
live reveal I'm your host for this
evening Trevor Noah and I'm so excited
to be here introducing this new edition
of battlefield which for some reason
everyone has really assumed is
battlefield 5 I mean and not battlefield
V could be V why not v battlefield V
could be just as good yeah I do love
that fans on Twitter actually changing
the V's in their profiles for this game
something my mother did many years ago
ahead of the curve and most people don't
know this but the V and my name is
actually a 5 yeah
my name is actually pronounced Trev 5 or
Noah very unique as a huge fan of these
games I've always loved how captivating
the battlefield is and today you'll see
that battlefield 5 has the most
immersive battlefield ever if you've
ever been in a battle with me you know
that I'm the most dedicated support
class you will ever meet I'm in the mud
repairing the tanks you know I'm laying
down mines as tank rushes come in one
time I even repaired a plane midair that
might be alive but I'm sticking with it
because you see I love that glorious joy
of being the uncelebrated hero in a
battle and this game is going to have
tons of moments like that there are so
many new and exciting features coming to
you in battlefield 5 that you will learn
about today the next level of
large-scale multiplayer battlefield 5
single-player war stories and we'll
start showing you the epic post-launch
journey all players will experience when
the game is finally released
and you know we've got some other
surprises so why waste time let's get
straight into it and get the show
started I'm joined now by the producers
of battlefield 5 andreas morel ryan
macarthur and loves Gustafson everybody
gentlemen I'm not here as a professional
anything I am here as a gamer I am here
as a battlefield player I'm here to ask
only the questions I am interested in
you have made a horrible mistake the
start at the beginning you are taking
players back to where the battlefield
French I started World War two now at
this point are you are you like those
guys you know those elderly pilots that
they find out an island in the Pacific
you know could think that the war never
ended is that who you are right now it
did you told me we had to break it to
you gently Louis but I want to go back
to that now to be honest with you it's
really I mean we joined four years to go
back to where it all started in about 16
years ago and you know technology as of
all of them the team has gotten gained
so much experience that this is really
the game we wanted to build them that we
did it's really something the guys back
home at dice is really passionate about
the whole era just ask mr. battlefield
he was he was there
mr. battlefield that's was his nickname
by the way I'm known as madam
battlefields now player players have
experienced World War two in in so many
movies and in games it's really
difficult to come up with a new and
fresh perspective what perspective are
you bringing to it with this version of
Battlefield andreas will this be more
Saving Private Ryan or inglorious
basterds so we've seen all the movies
you know we play the games we've been
there I'm I'm pretty sure at least I can
navigate half of France without maps
just by playing the game so so for us
going back to to where it all began for
us it's really about delivering World
War two experience that no one's ever
never seen before really can i hitting
on the unseen locations to untold
stories there unplayed moments yeah i
mean for us it's really taking you on
the journey from the start and at a go
you will be able to play the German
forces the British forces and we want to
take you on that journey you know to
exotic places like freezing
Scandinavia Heights can Holmes are but
in Norway or or ragged desert
it's where the battles took place in
northern Africa why not today the ruins
of the ones are beautiful Rotterdam so
it's really to take you on a journey and
we want to do this with a kind of a
fresh and modern take
and so really hopefully surprise to
players but also to please them you've
given me a sneak peek and so many words
come to my mind I mean intense immense
powerful Ryan do you have a specific way
that you want players to see this
battlefield I think the best way we can
describe it is immersive I mean this
this needs to feel like the most
immersive battlefield that the players
have ever played I mean we want them to
exploit the battlefield in ways they've
never been able to before I mean when
you look at the chaotic multiplayer that
the franchise is known for and sort of
fan classics like conquest and some of
the new modes that the guys are working
on like airborne you know we're going
back with the war story sort of that
anthology storytelling that we had we
built in the f1 and telling new stories
about men and women that changed history
I mean we get to tell everyone say that
that co-op is back in battlefield five
and that's a huge thing for us and this
is just the beginning I mean launch is
just the beginning for this game and we
really want to take players on a journey
through World War two it always feels
like it's a journey that's what it
always feels like with battlefields like
one thing I loved about the game was how
the maps in the world was constantly
changing you know I felt like my bedroom
at home I never knew what to expect and
I think when looking at this game
andreas what's your vision to take this
to the next level so we're really
building on what we started with
previous games it's it's really about
giving players the most immersive world
that they could enter you should really
be grounded in it's expanding on the
movement said the way we're done so well
really pushing all these new features
that we're gonna be talking about right
it sounds great
I'm genuinely excited I have a few
highlights that I'm looking forward to
let's dive into it and talk about some
of the gameplay here to do that is
Daniel Berlin a battlefield 5 we're
expanding the tool box for the player
giving you access to new abilities to
create your own and brand new
battlefield moments now there's a deeper
connection between the player and the
world around you you will be physically
pushed by the shockwave from explosions
you can experience completely new ways
to traverse and
tactically maneuver across the
battlefield with our overhauled movement
system our renowned destruction will rip
up the terrain live chunks of masonry
hanging from destroyed buildings or have
high-caliber rounds with straight
through walls to take out two enemies
hiding inside we're also bringing back
classic modes such as majority rule
conquest but we also have new modes and
experiences for our unique take on world
war 2 we're bringing back operations
with a bang and we're calling it grand
operations here you'll experience
multiple game modes as you fight over
multiple Maps all wrapped with an hour
narrative journey through historic
inspired battles from World War two with
the return of our anthology formats for
singer play war stories with new
characters to meet and untold stories to
discover back to you Trevor
now Daniel just talked about a new
multiplayer experience called grand
operations and I'm really excited
because it sounds to me like you can
pilot a giant grand piano like a tank
I'm pretty certain that's what it is
right and dress I'm sure about the piano
but it's definitely massive it's it's
really about really being all these
power fantasies from world war ii like
airborne being power dropped in and its
operations from battle for one but big
it's really good yeah I mean what we
want players to feel like it's sort of a
dynamic player impacted experience take
taken place over for fictional days I
mean day one starts with you jumping out
of an airplane and with the objective to
to destroy the enemy artillery with that
M&E sort of entrenching themselves to
defend and protect and depending on how
the outcome of day one goes for you as
the two as the two main forces start to
battle over day two in a game of
breakthrough with a number of lives you
have left remaining depending on what
you did the day before and then as you
continue to push on into new locations
we're gonna see things like conquest
assault where players continue to fight
for that terrain and assuming you know
when we see these these players end up
in a giant stalemate then they're gonna
enter a day for which is final stand and
I mean this is this is sort of tired
muddy no resources left you've got just
you your squad and one
one clip and you all fight to the last
men standing with the weight of the
world on your shoulders so this is a
game mode that you may never see if your
games are not in a stalemate you may
never get to that fourth map and fourth
story then exactly that's an exciting
way to play the game I want to know when
we can see more of that two weeks
Airplane Los Angeles you get hands-on
multi play for the first time if you're
there so even the reveal of grand
operations spans across multiple events
Wow I I have to say I I heard you guys
say that co-op is back and that's one of
my favorite aspects of battlefield one
laws can you tell me more about that
mode I definitely can I mean I'm happy
to say that for the first time since
battlefield 3 co-op is back and we're
calling it two combined arms and here
it's just another way to get experience
that battlefield sandbox you know next
to our war stories and the multiplayer
and what we want to do here is to allow
you and up to three players to go online
and step into those shoes of the
Pathfinders those paratroopers that go
in behind enemy lines and here you
really only have to soldier next to you
maybe not Brian yeah as you move forward
since you know getting detected might
mean death and you will soon be struck
by resource scarcity you need to find
the tools and find your way to the
objective so stakes are high and you
need to kind of assess can I push
through or do we need to extract our
leads it's kind of win or lose it's up
to you I've been a huge fan of war
stories the single-player campaign in
battlefield 1 what I what I truly
enjoyed about it was I felt like I was
learning about the stories behind the
war and playing through the stories of
the war and it didn't always end well
and what I loved is because of that
history elements like I for instance I
told my little brother I said hey if mom
ever catches you playing just say this
is a history class that you're doing on
the console and then what I'll do is
I'll tell my mom he was gonna do that so
she would know that I was always her
favorites and what was great was seeing
this story laws like how is
single-player gonna change in
battlefield 5 don't tell this to my kids
all right let's change they got me to me
I'm happy that you like the war stories
and for us the war stories are really
our opportunity to put the war into
perspective it's really about this human
and untold stories of the war and we try
to portray those kind of real and
relatable people facing epic warfare and
it's its battlefield after all so we'll
be talking a lot here today about the
gameplay improvement so play your agency
is key so you can create your own
battlefield moments and at the bottom
line it's about allowing you to witness
the Second World War but through the
eyes of the men and women that changed
the world I mean as you can see here I
mean this is one of the war stories that
we're gonna be talking about first I
mean this is our North East story this
is the story of a young woman who is
part of the Norwegian resistance
fighters fighting the German occupation
during World War two
I mean this is an exploration of emotion
and feelings
it's a family story yeah you know and
this not only sort of really grounds the
players in the reality but sort of sets
the context of the world war two that
we're trying to create at dice it's not
often that you find stories that connect
with the emotion of the characters in
the story and instead of just focusing
on the explosions in the gunfire you see
that look in her eyes you want to know
what she's thinking what she's
experiencing in that story why was it so
important for you to focus on the people
behind the stories from war well I think
it's it's important to tell you know
sort of believable in sort of honest
stories and really sort of set the
context and sort of main that maintain
that connection to the world that we're
trying to create I think it's important
for for people to understand where we're
coming from and what our what our
particular take is on world war two so
what we're gonna do right now is we're
gonna go back to Daniel now to cover
what you'll take to the battlefield with
you
in battlefield five we're aiming to
mirror the immense arsenal of the Second
World War this was a period that saw an
explosion in terms of innovation when it
comes to weapons and vehicles you will
get to fly iconic airplanes engage in
incredible tank battles and also unleash
secret weapons for world war ii weapons
that are powerful enough to turn the
tide of any battle and with the new
fortification system you can be more
strategic than ever in how
you choose to defend or advance through
the terrain back to you guys you know in
playing battlefield I know everyone in
the audience will agree with me people
at home as well I've always been
impressed by the level of realism in the
game I remember once I was playing with
a friend who served in Special Forces
and we were talking about our favorite
guns and I was talking about the recoil
and what I liked about the sights versus
other guns and he turned to me at one
point he said oh where did you serve and
I felt embarrassed cuz I was like all
battlefield 3 that's that's where I was
and instead of him being angry he was
like I didn't know that there was a game
that was that immersive something that
really was as true to real without being
a war simulation as possible guys tell
me about some of your favorite weapons
in the game some of the new vehicles
that will be available in battlefield 5
I think
first just by going back to this era we
can the pool of hardware that we can
choose from is immense there's so much
there and for me being a vehicle guy
it's really quite simple choice it's the
tire you want to take one tear I think
it's the most iconic tank from this era
I just think it's amazing what what do
you what do you like about it that's a
weird choice for me have you seen it I
think is the best
what like the looks but also checking
out a tank in a battle with that yeah
but I've never looked at it I'm like if
I'm on the outside I'm dying if I'm on
the inside I'm concentrating I mean when
are you looking what are you doing this
Troy third-person camera and just run
around the tank dying and there was
gonna be like who's that guy looking at
the tank it's beautiful
I'll take your word for it yeah so
undress is a tank guy
mr. battlefield laws how about you we've
been trying to hide it the fact that I'm
also support plane I can't hit a barn
from the inside so I need the big flips
and for me the mg42 is really the weapon
I play in the place right man it has
that iconic sound that you know sense
fear all over the map and and they're
not a part of it is the new kind of
system which Daniel talked about for a
high-caliber weapon
so previously I could make the same
impact as a pistol basically but this
time around it comes with a punch so
where the pistol gets stuck in the wall
I can rip through so I can finally make
a difference on the battlefield
hashtag no more knocking I like alright
so we thank guy we've got a weapons guy
Ryan well sort of embarrassing two
minutes unlike Lars I can't hit a bar in
period so for me it's the toolbox in
battle one all players had a gas mask
and B F about to the fight we're gonna
replace that gas mask for the toolbox so
that means I can run around the
battlefield with my toolbox setting up
fortifications and and sort of really
change in the dynamic of the battlefield
so that these guys who can actually hit
something I can offer offer some value
in the playing field what wait so
fortifications you just skimmed over
that but what is what is fortifications
well I mean this as like as a support
point I think this is this is something
you're really love is something III
think is a great addition to the game it
really allows you to sort of players
want to focus on the objective I mean
this is this is something you can sort
of pull out your toolbox you can you
know build reinforcements you can
reinforce buildings that Andreas has
destroyed with his tank you can build
foxholes and set up machine guns so
people like Lars can sit there and camp
out at choke points I mean this is going
to change the strategic way people pay
both as attackers and defenders is that
was that in response to the gaming
community because I know as a
battlefield gamer I always wanted what I
didn't have so first I was going hey
guys I need destruction I need places to
fall apart and then at some point is
like too much destruction too much
destruction like there's nothing left
was this a response yeah I mean we've
had a lot of esteemed players in here in
the studio today and in the community
overall who at some point especially
when we're testing kind of we came to a
point where the level was level one was
level then you couldn't advance so
basically this is to counter that and
give you an additional kind of toolbox
to to rebuild and then you and I can
come in as he rose again and they
fortify we come down and we add an index
an extra I have a machine gun or an a a
gun so it's kind of teamwork once again
and we are the celebrated heroes we have
a celebrated hero heroes we deserve to
be thanked you now now that we've
learned about the tools let's hear about
of the company here to tell us more
please welcome Natalie
yeck
cover and yes the company is something
that is completely new to battlefield 5
it's your personal collection I've
customized soldiers weapons and vehicles
that you can tailor and grow as you play
the company is the heart and soul of a
personal experience and the choices you
make here for your company actually
matters not only with your choices
affect the way you look but also how
your weapons and vehicles play as you
squat up with your friends make sure to
pick a soldier that complements the rest
of your squad to take on the battle
ahead and during the game adapt to the
change in circumstances by chat by
calling your company and bring in the
right soldier weapon or vehicle to suit
your situation back to your trevor
andres that really sounds awesome tell
me more about the company and how it
works because you know I know from my
years in battlefield that the group that
rarely plays together stays together
now the company is something that we
super excited about for first time you
can now create your own personal
experience with the soldiers to take on
to the battlefield it's really up to you
to decide how you want them to play and
also how they how they look so as you
keep playing and you get better your
soldiers will get better with you so
give me an example of how this would
impact me as a support class so if you
take your support class whether you want
you start playing with that with that
with that soldier and you start
progressing you're gonna unlock you know
a set of new abilities new perks and
sort of these new exotic ways to play
the game as a support class and then you
know unlock new weapons for yourself to
play when you take that machine gun that
Lars loved so much and you level that
machine gun up you make the choices that
matter and then you decide well I think
this needs its own custom paint job so
you sort of make that machine gun really
make it your own
and then you go in and you grab that
that sort of iconic support outfit that
you really want to wear going in the
bottle you jump in with some friends and
off you go you know it's funny you
brought up customization because I've
always believed in battlefield the team
is important but looking badass is the
most important thing I think anyone
who's been in war can agree with this
please tell me that I can customize my
look to be properly badass in the
battlefield well yeah of course I mean
if it's worth doing it's worth doing
looking good right so I think you know
part of the tactical gameplay that comes
with battlefield I mean what we want to
do is give you the ability to create
your own personal identity so you know
no more anonymous soldiers you know this
is your soldiers and their boots going
into battle
their own weapons customized the way
that you want to do it the gear that you
want them to wear I mean this is this is
gonna feel like it's your own personal
Arsenal and obviously I want to get as
much of that Arsenal as I can possibly
get how do how do I even begin getting
all of this gear you play the game I
mean for what we want players is you get
rewarded for playing the game yeah I
mean it's pretty short it's whatever you
want to progress towards your company
your class or a specific items you play
the game and we set out to commit to
that you always feel rewarded for what
you do
whatever you play she just played to to
unlock these items then I guess I have
to ask and I know it's a sensitive
subject but I'm still gonna go there is
this game going to be pay to win no you
can't pay to get an unfair game play
advantage what if I have a lot of money
so you'll be able to pay No so in
battlefield it's always been about a
balance rock-paper-scissor gameplay and
it's still this you really have to like
less for saying you have to play the
game at a new gear and skill is really
key okay but what about premium pass
will it be one of those games where I
have to shell out another 50 bucks six
months after I've bought the game is
that how it works
well I guess I guess I get the fun part
of not taking any more of your money as
well but no there's no more premium pass
in this game this means
I mean this means no more paying for
maps no more paying for modes you know
this is some of the community has asked
for this is something the team really
believes and so what we want is a game
where people stay together they play the
games together and they get to go on
this journey through world war two
together that's beautiful that means I
finally lose my nickname no Maps Noah
all right well it's time to learn about
what happens after the game launches so
to tell us all about live service please
welcome back Natalie and Daniel
so launch is really just the beginning
title war is an epic journey that you
and your company will take through World
War two it will bring you an evolving
diverse game that will grow over time as
we immerse you and your company in
different theatres of war playing
battlefield 5 is an experience unlike
any other it will differ from all
previous Battlefield games and the most
important thing it's open to all players
yes and there will always be new battles
new France and rewards on the horizon
and by removing premium pass we are
keeping the community together so this
time there will be no expansion packs
and all players will be able to take
part in the same journey through battle
five and we types of war our players
will experience theme chapters of World
War two
each spanning over several months and
these will focus on key moments that
impact the outcome of the conflict
Trevor this sounds to me like a wild
full ride through World War two but laws
like how big of a journey will this be
long it's a training no I mean to put it
into perspective this was a world war
and I mean to me it's gonna be a huge
journey I mean we want to take you on
that journey with chapters from the
history and at the end of it we'll
really want you to be kind of
experiences daily weekly and monthly
events leading up to you kind of the
pinnacle of the grand operations and
experience to achieve those special
assignments
treated with extra rewards so so it is
about keeping it fresh and constantly
evolving since what we see here and
talked about here today's it's just just
the beginning and as you play it through
you start to be taken to new horizons
new locations new gameplay and I mean
stay game for the ride it sounds like
it's gonna be one of those experiences
where the more I play the more cool
stuff I can get I get rewarded for my
time is that gonna be across different
modes it's again it's really simple you
just have to play the game to a new cool
and doesn't matter if it's multiplayer
or
combined-arms like like you see here you
will be able to earn new vehicles new
weapons it's gonna be dog tags and
soldier skins weapon skin it's all there
to really customize your your crew to
really be standing out on the
battlefield the way you want it to be
right it sounds amazing and I only have
one question and that is when does this
all start well the game launches in
October so starting November running
through early 2019 we're gonna start
with our first chapter which is going to
focus on the fall of Europe so we're
gonna we're gonna explore so the German
mechanized war machine as it pushes its
way into Europe this is going to be live
gameplay focused events we're gonna have
themed attic rewards tied to this you
know we can't wait to talk to the
community more about this between as we
lead up to launch yeah I'm not gonna lie
you guys have definitely raised my
analog stick and I think we've waited
long enough this is the most immersive
battlefield yet in a world war 2 you
have never seen before
we're launch is just the beginning of
the journey I'm done talking I think
it's time we see this thing are you you
already well here it is ladies in
general first time ever the reveal
trailer for battlefield 5
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
hello
[Music]
[Applause]
yes Wow Wow the car the thing the man
the boo you saw the thing man
uh-huh hopefully got insurance that was
insane do you see that that was
addressed I don't feel like you saw I
feel like you've seen it before my mom
jumped on their back and then started
shooting while moving on their back yeah
it's cool this is what happens when you
live life in a tank andreas amazing Wow
wait so before we go before we go am I
correct in saying there was some new
animations that there was some new news
that you could you could do in the game
there's a few yeah okay thank you I
think we should thank the team back home
it's Colin helping us to get to this
point I think they are truly amazing and
our fans again we've been waiting for
this moment for so long to be able to
reveal what we've been working on this
is really packed with gameplay and I
mean a lot of days this is direct
feedback from community leading to a lot
of these improvements so it's a huge
thank you for for the support and once
again the team for doing a extraordinary
up as always the look on your face you
know in kids the mark they're going for
him yeah yeah yeah yeah I mean I'm
excited I'm excited give it up for the
people in Stockholm
Wow battlefield 5 launches worldwide on
October 19th in the meantime these guys
are giving away free expansion packs in
battlefield 1 and battlefield 4 so just
head to battlefield comm for all the
details and next up is EA play on June
9th where you'll see multiplayer for the
very first time I hope all of you are as
excited as I am for Battlefield 5 to
watch that trailer again go to
youtube.com forward slash Battlefield
and if you want more info join some of
the team here with Xbox who are hosting
an exclusive post show on mixer comm 4 /
Xbox that is our show for tonight
thank you so much for joining us
everybody I'm Trevor Noah good night
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]